where we had left off we'd use the
information from these two lines to
figure out two vectors which are really
just almost you could just say two
position vectors lying in this white
plane and we took their cross product to
find a vector that's perpendicular
that's normal to this entire that's it
normal to this entire white plane and
that was vector d there and vector d
will have to sit will have to sit
especially if when you know to visualize
it if you start the vector you can
always position a vector anywhere you
want but if you start it at 0 it will
clearly sit in that plane but since you
can always position it anywhere you can
say okay let's start it at 0. so it will
sit in this yellow plane that we need to
find the equation for and we know vector
d sits in it we already know that vector
a sits in it we got that early on in the
in the first video on this problem and
so we can take the cross product of d
and a to find a normal vector to it and
then using that normal vector and then
thinking about what an arbitrary point
in or what an arbitrary vector on this
plane might look like we can then figure
out the equation for this yellow plane
we already touched on it a little bit in
the in the linear algebra playlist if
any of this stuff makes you confused and
just a reminder we take the cross
product of two vectors in three
dimensional space it will give you a
third vector that is perpendicular to
both that's the whole kind of tool that
we're using over here
so let's just take the cross product of
d and a so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to so for the
i we have 1 times 4 which is 4 minus 3
times 10. so 4 minus 30 is negative 26.
so we have negative 26 i
and then we have
negative or minus for j we have to swap
signs for the j and so we have negative
8 times 4 is negative 32
negative 32 minus 2 times 10. so minus
20 is negative 52. so we put a negative
52 here or we could just say positive 52
because it's nega it's minus negative 52
which is the same thing as plus 52 j and
then finally for the k cross out that
row that column negative 8 times 3 is
negative 24 minus 2 times 1 so minus 2
is negative 26 so minus 20
minus 26 k
so this normal vector right here or or a
vector that is normal to the yellow
plane the plane that we have to find the
equation of is this over here and just
because it kind of pops out at me that
all of these are divisible by 26 i'm
going to define another i'm going to
define another normal vector i don't
know let's call it we could call it
anything let me call it
i don't know let's let's call it
let's call it p or let's call it i don't
know let's call it normal
normal
one i mean just to show it's a different
vector i don't i'm just going to divide
although it's essentially it's pointing
in the same direction it has the same
direction just different magnitude i'm
just going to divide all of these by
negative 26. so if i divide all of these
by negative 26 i'm just scaling the
vector but it's still going to go in the
same direction because that's what i
care about i care about just a finding
any vector finding any vector that is
normal that is normal to this
to this yellow plane right here i want
to find any vector i already found one
and now i'm just going to scale it down
so that it's a simpler vector so if i
divide everything by negative 26 i get i
plus
or i should say minus
minus 2 j
plus k
so that might look something like this
right over there so this is our
n1 vector that's normal to this
now just using this we can now figure
out the equation of this plane right
here so let's just think about a little
bit let's just say i have a point or i
could even say a position vector xyz and
i know x y z sits on this plane
so x y
z it sits on this plane and we know that
the point zero zero zero is on the plane
so we also know that the position vector
we also know that the position vector
x i
plus
y j plus z k
have to sit on this yellow plane in
question i'm assuming that x y z is a
point on this plane i could have put i
could have put little knots here just to
make sure that you know this could be a
particular point on this plane or this
is i'm just saying this is just any
point that i'm defining to be on this
plane
now this position vector will then be on
this plane and since this vector is
normal to this position vector right
here
or in other words it's perpendicular or
it's orthogonal if i were to take the
dot product of this
if i were to take the dot product if i
were to take that and then dot it with
this vector right over here and dot it
with that vector right over there so i
would take the dot product of that and
this
y
y j plus z k
if i take the dot product of these two
things it has to be it has to be equal
to zero if i take the dot product of two
vectors that are orthogonal to each
other and by definition these two
vectors are i'm saying that this guy
this guy is in the plane
this vector we already figured out this
vector we already figured out is
perpendicular to the plane which means
it's perpendicular it's orthogonal to
everything in the plane so if we take
their dot product it will be equal to
zero so what does that give us so if we
take their dot product we get x times
one so if we get let me just go term by
term so if we take
x times the coefficient there's one so
we have x
plus
y times negative two
so i should really call that i well i
could just call that negative two y
and then finally
finally i have z times one there's a one
in front of this k it's implicitly there
so z times 1 so plus
so plus z that's the dot product and
that has to be equal to 0. or another
way to write it just to simplify it a
little bit is that x minus 2y
plus z
is equal to 0. and that is the equation
of our plane in question or i should
actually write it in yellow because it's
the yellow blade x minus 2y plus z is
equal to 0. and i know this might have
been a little daunting or a little
confusing
if you actually had to do this in exam
you wouldn't have to do all of the
explanation but
just to visualize what we did we use
these these two lines you can kind of
view the the vectors we use is kind of
the slopes of these lines in three
dimensions don't worry about that if
that confuses you but we used vectors
in we both of these specify a different
vector you could keep scaling them and
do whatever but we just took their cross
product to find a vector that is normal
to this entire white plane and it would
have to sit in the yellow plane now if
it sits on the yellow plane we could
take the cross product of that with the
first vector that we found fit that was
in the yellow plane the a vector that
sat on that line or you can almost do it
as the slope of that line in three
dimensions
and if you take the cross product of
that it's not exactly the slope i don't
want y'all to knit pigments no it's not
exactly slow but a vector in three
dimensions is kind of specifying a
direction which is analogous to a slope
in two directions in two dimensions but
if we take the cross product of these
two vectors now we'll get a normal
vector that's what we started this video
doing i scaled back this normal vector
just to simplify the math i said okay if
i have this normal vector and any
arbitrary vector on this plane when i
take their dot product it'll be zero and
so what that allowed us to do is figure
out what those what are the constraints
on that x y and z any x y and z that's
on the plane when i take the dot product
of that position vector with the normal
vector it has to be equal to zero so
that gave us the cons the actual
constraints for the plane anyway
hopefully you found that fun